While I did vote for Kamala,
I'm not gonna completely cut off people in my life
that did vote for Donald Trump.
I'm a woman, I'm a Latina,
I'm like, definitely a hardcore fucking advocate.
I have a daughter that's disabled,
she's on an IEP. You know,
she's at a higher risk for many things
because I was once that super close minded
but good hearted person that did not understand, like, true,
I know it sounds like you've gotta be fucking stupid to not get it.
I promise you, I was one of them, I,
I was, I was one of those women that would say like, yeah,
I think it'd be okay if maybe just,
you know, the husband cast the vote for the family
and then like, for as many people in your family,
like, maybe
that's as many votes as your husband gets to cast in the election.
So, like,
for us, because we're married with four kids,
we would have like, you would get six votes
and we just all would submit to what your vote is.
Like, there are people that are that brainwashed
that think in their heart that that would make a better world.
Like, you'll see.
Like, I promise you,
once we get there, you'll understand and you'll thank me.
Like, exactly the same way you feel,
they feel the same way, but just mirror that shit.
But also the same kind heart that you have that you want to see.
Good. In the world,
they have that too. And so if you completely cut them off,
two things happen. Number one,
it just creates such a deeper divide,
which is not what we need
ever. You know what I mean?
I think that's a very rash decision
and it's a very emotionally filled decision.
And I don't really think it gets anyone anywhere.
I think the better thing to do,
and this is what I do.
And unfortunately sometimes the relationships will still end.
No, we're still gonna be in relationship.
I'm just. I'm not going to filter it.
I'm not gonna put the rose colored tint on my stories
to make you feel better. I'm gonna talk about my life and my struggles
and the things that I go through earnestly and honestly with you,
my friend.
And if I can weave in how certain politics maybe have affected that,
I'm going to. And I'm gonna let you sit with that,
because that's the only way change happens.
Like I don't.
There was a vice documentary about this black dude that has converted
like 400 KKK members or something.
He's even gotten like a grand marshal or some shit.
It's a fucking really wild story.
It's available on YouTube and you can Google it
cause it's a very fucking famous story.
I'm pretty sure the dude is still alive and well
and living in the south and still on his mission.
He goes into their spaces and helps teach Them.
I just think there's different people
with different abilities in this world.
That's what makes it a beautiful place.
We all have different dynamics,
we all see the world through different lenses.
And we can only speak to the people that we speak to.
And so for me personally, I'm not like,
fuck you, get out of my life.
Block, block,
block, block,
block it now I'm illuminated.
I did go and see which people of mine follow him on
you on fucking Instagram or whatever.
But you know, for me personally,
that's my decision.
And I just wanted to share it for other people to consider.
Because if it weren't for my friends that stayed in my life
and helped me see the injustices.
Because that kind heart is gonna speak to that kind heart,
you know what I mean? Everything else is details.
The kindness is the same, the heart is the same.
And if those people would have deserted me,
it would have only driven me deeper.
Cause I would have had nowhere else to go. So.